Far Cry primal available februari 23rd
hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to a
stone-age episode of in two minutes now
as you can tell by the sponsorship
bumper this episode is brought to you by
far cry primal which got me thinking how
can a far cry game be a far cry game if
it doesn't have any of the Far Cry
staples like guns or vehicles or Wing
suits or yes even lasers but then again
I suppose you don't really need all this
technology gump to clobber the absolute
hell out of some bad guys huh let's find
out so I suppose the main thing they
didn't have back in the Stone Age was
vehicles previous far cry so let us
Traverse an array of tropical locales
via various means from boats and jeeps
to Wing suits and mini choppers has
always been a lot of ways to get around
in primal though locomotion is
distinctly more low-tech you either walk
or hitch a ride on the back of a
galavanting great mammoth and while i
miss the local tittie radio station i do
enjoy boring people to death with my
tusky ride ok 1.2 Stone Age second
biggest thing is that there's no guns
grenades or any other kind of man-made
explosives so that far cry mainstay the
bow and arrow are probably gonna be your
best friend in primal pinning enemies
with the wealth long spear may not be as
satisfying as say blowing everyone up at
the rocket launcher but clubbing someone
to death from above will never get old
and I guess if it does you can always
get your pet owl to drop a load of
bloody bees on top of everyone speaking
of Hedwig as I called her she also helps
to compensate for the lack of binoculars
tagging enemies with your bizarrely high
spec binoculars is usually the best way
of keeping track of people in Far Cry
but seeing as glasses as we know them
weren't invented until the ancient
Romans we have to resort to our old our
buddy to give everyone on the
battlefield an ocular pat-down one thing
we take for granted with video games is
that they're usually in the language
that you speak while stowage man
definitely didn't sound like captain
caveman or say things like me
man fire bad he probably didn't speak
the Queen's English either seeing as we
don't really know the language that was
spoken all those tens of thousands of
years ago ubisoft's developers got some
language experts to make a very educated
guess so subtitles them and finally
there's no co-op in Far Cry primal so
while you may be lamenting the fact that
you can't have your buddies drop in and
help you out at a moment's notice you do
however have a vast array of big tooth
animals at your beck and call to come to
your site a mall well anybody you tell
them to and admittedly they do make
taming animals look a lot easier and
safer than it actually is don't try this
the next time you go to the zoo so there
we are how far cry primal can still be a
far cry game despite having none of the
Far Cry technology that we come to
expect a [ __ ] Far Cry primal make sure
you check out the gist this week we're
just talks about the five coolest things
you can do in the game and my episode of
reality check on Friday where I take a
look at the technology of stone age man
thanks for watching this week's episode
of in two minutes don't forget you can
find me on Twitter at Lucy James games
and I'll see you next time